This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, This is Chris
Abraham.
This is the Chris Abraham Show.
This is season five Episode
Dente Siete.
That is episode 27.
And I'm just popping in because
I saw the first interview of
Tucker Carlson since he was
fired by Fox and that interview
was conducted by Russell Brand
and it was just.
It was just, you know, a bunch
of confirmation bias and
affirmation bias.
Just a bunch of like, huh,
That's what I thought, Huh.
That's what I thought, huh.
That's what I thought.
And I was very entertaining.
It was, you know, I don't know
if I support or don't support
the nudging narrative of the
current, you know?
Western hegemony in terms of its
imperialism, both warmongering
abroad, being the most colonial
country in the world, while
without blinking telling every
country that America's colonized
along with Great Britain that it
is in fact a free democracy.
To the point of us having
between 800 and over 1000, quote
UN quote, bases in sovereign
countries, whether it be
military bases or intelligence
bases or collaborative state
department, I guess embassies
and so on and so forth so.
With that being said, it was
just a pleasure to sit there for
an hour and listen to Tucker
Carlson chat with Russell Brand.
These two men are, I think, at
an opposite, opposing part of
the horseshoe of the.
Liberal and conservative
horseshoe.
And yet they are fast friends.
And why is that?
The most important part of the
interview was the fact that the
concept of left and right has
either broken down or become
have discovered more in common
with each other visibly.
The horseshoe of populism where
extreme left and extreme right.
Have more in common, and
hitherto have found enough
separating them that they're
unwilling to agree on anything,
even though they agree on
everything.
For example, all of my extreme
leftist friends never took the
shot.
All of my extreme rightist
friends refused to take the
shot.
My extreme leftist friends.
Want to eat fresh, whole,
organic, unprocessed foods?
And my extreme rightist friends
are obsessed with fitness,
health, organics, and a lack of
processed foods.
My extreme leftist friends try
to find plant medicine as a way
of being healthy.
Plant medicine can be, if you
will.
Eastern Medicine.
Did I ever tell you that when I
lived in Germany, Germans really
try to steer you away into
holistic solutions rather than
medical solutions?
I feel like the left and the
right agree on one thing, which
is they are trying to remain out
of the pocket of pharma.
Out of the pocket of processed
foods, out of the out of the
pockets of pharmacologicals, out
of quick solutions such as
Ozempic into they both seem to
often agree when it comes to
solutions such as I don't know.
I forgot the term for for kind
of a a type of self-discipline
and temperance that is more
interested in personal choice
and personal agency and kind of.
I feel like they've embraced
libertarianism and even.
Anarchism over libertinism and
self indulgence and both the
extreme left and the extreme
right is really anti tyrannical
and anti autocracy.
In other words, while
theoretical I meaning Russell
Brand.
And Tucker Carlson said the
following I feel like by this
I'm quasi quoting Russell Brand
and Tucker Carlson, while I want
to have complete agency and
autonomy over raising my
children with an asterisk that
says that abusive families who
abuse their children.
Should not be included in this.
I also need to believe that if
I'm allowed autocracy, sorry
autonomy and agency and
independence when it comes to
how I raise my children, I also
need to accept the fact that I
cannot tell other parents how to
raise their children.
Because when I say.
I want autonomy and agency in
terms of how I raise my
children.
That has the other edge of the
sword, which is to say I have no
agency or control over the way
other people raise their
children.
I agree with that.
I chose not to have children, so
I don't have to make that
decision, but I believe that.
My only attachment to
libertarianism is because it's a
signifier that lets me tell
everybody else that I am willing
to cede to you your full
autonomy and agency, under the
understanding that I get my own
agency and autonomy and if you
try to influence me.
Or tell me what to do.
I will respond very badly and
very dangerously, but only if
you try to intervene in my
autonomy and intervene in my
agency.
And I think that this is what I
loosely defined as populism, but
it's a messy word, because I use
that word only.
Because it inflames people and
pisses people off.
But what I really mean is the
fact that Tucker Carlson, or
maybe it was Russell Brand, they
become like the same person in
my head for the purposes of this
conversation, did say one thing
that autocracy and
authoritarianism in America now.
Is defined as centrism, and that
the left and the right are any
and all things that do not
agree.
Or what is the term homo.
The do not assimilate with what
the centrism is, which is what
is called leftism, but is in
fact centrism and is in fact
American.
Authority, American
authoritarianism and American,
not dictatorship.
But I mean, surely
authoritarianism.
And surely that if you do not
agree with a narrative, you mean
one could call it fascism.
But one could call it fascism
with the lower case, which is
authoritarianism Always, always,
always question someone who
believes that that fascism needs
to only be clothed by Hugo Boss.
That if you are not a blue eyed,
blonde haired ubermensch.
With a German accent, German
ethnicity, and if you if your
concept of fascism is only
defined as a jackbooted thug and
not loosely designed defined as
any thug at all, it is really
important to you know,
reconsider your your definition.
I mean, what is your definition?
What is your issue with needing
to redefine what oversteering?
I mean, if you need to be one
thing that Tucker and Brand
agreed upon, which is it's not a
if your government trusts you,
if your government distrusts
you, and if your government,
sorry.
If you distrust your government,
if a huge population of 7171
million people distrust the
government, distrust the vote,
distrust the election, and
distrust the entire idea of
America being a democracy at
all, and in fact fears that the
narrative is already.
Decided who becomes President?
Who becomes Governor?
Who becomes Senator?
Who becomes Rep if there is no
way that you can force 71
million people into believing
you.
The more you try to force 71
million people into believing
you, the more you reaffirm to
those 71 million people in
growing.
That this is in fact a what is
it called a a Banana Republic?
That this is in fact a puppet
government?
That this is in fact a Kabuki
dance, That this is in fact
political theater, and that
whatever your decision in the
voting booth is mere formality?
As an indulgence, if you will,
Not unlike is it Maggie or Lisa.
Maggie.
Not unlike when Maggie is in the
passenger seat of the car being
driven by I forgot what it's
it's Homer Simpson and it's Lisa
Simpson.
And it's Bart Simpson.
I don't know.
Mona Simpson.
Mona.
I don't think I knew that.
Voiced by Maggie Roswell?
No.
Is it right?
Marge.
Marge Simpson.
Duh, Marge Simpson.
So.
So it's a it's like one of it's
one of the opening scenes in The
Simpsons where they're driving
in the car and Marge, the adult
is driving the car.
But Maggie, I assume is a little
baby, is in her own, in her own
car seat, and she has her own.
Steering wheel and its own horn.
And she is given a belief.
She is.
She has the the play she is.
She has no actual ability to
drive the car.
She has no input.
She doesn't even have a voice.
She is a an infant, a permanent
infant and.
But she has complete access to a
steering wheel and she has
complete access to a horn, and
she has access to a a type of
driver's seat.
But the horn, the driver's seat
and the steering wheel are not
attached to anything.
And that's sort of what 71
million Americans believe is the
truth.
And so Russell and.
And Tucker were basically saying
that you can't force those
people into believing you.
You have to.
You have to convince them
through apology, transparency,
honesty, and through apology
through actually deep apology
and.
And you have to win back their
trust.
But if you have nothing but
contempt for your population,
and if you've defined them as a
bunch of Magga Cristofascists,
you're not going to have any
incentive to want to.
You've completely dismissed at
least 1/2 of your entire
population to the bin of
history.
And The funny thing is, is that
the same people who want to rule
America actually have passports
and the.
What is it?
Cosmopolitan nature and maybe
other passports and the money
associated with being able to
leave.
But the 71 million people who
are dismissed as Christo?
Fascist, MAGA extremist, MAGA
Super Republicans are actually
neither Republicans.
Neither, generally speaking,
crypto fascists.
The people who are MAGA
Republicans tend to be.
You know, populist way more than
they're Christians.
Most of them are.
Most of them have barely been to
church mostly.
Most of them fancy Sunday, where
you goes watch the game, not
where you go to church with your
wife or whatever.
I would say that they're barely
Christian.
They're barely traditional.
I'd say a lot of them have you
know babies, Mamas and and and O
child support and like are what
you know would be the opposite
of of necessarily 100% diddly do
highly ho neighbor.
I would say that this populist
uprising is mostly amongst the
underclass.
Is mostly amongst people who
aren't anti trans.
They just don't think about it.
Aren't anti-gay, they just don't
think about it.
Aren't anti anybody.
They just don't think about it.
They have jobs that require
sweating and wages as opposed to
salaries and very little power
and very little equity in the
world.
And they probably have a lot
more in common with poor black
folks than Bill Gates or Jeff
Bezos or Elon Musk or, to be
honest, Russell Brand or Tucker
Carlson or anybody.
And yet I believe that the race
war.
Is a distraction so as to create
as much of A divide between poor
white folk and poor black folk
and poor Indian folk and poor
indigenous folk and poor Latin
folk and poor Latino folk and
poor immigrant folk and poor
African folk and poor Middle
Eastern folk and all the other
folks who are.
Under Invested in and who will
never win the meritocracy wars,
and who don't even play in the
meritocracy wars, and who don't
even care about the meritocracy
wars.
Most people who are involved in
the meritocracy wars are going
to end up in the top 20% no
matter what.
They might not end up in the top
1%, but there's certainly never
if you if you prioritize.
Meritocracy.
Then you're going to at least
probably achieve a world where
you can have a living and you
probably will have access to
something and as opposed to
nothing.
And if you are in the
meritocracy game, you'll
probably be grateful for it and
not constantly disappointed or
unhappy.
I would recommend go seeing it.
I think it's very interesting.
I believe that January 6 is
simply the the new domestic 911.
I believe that it was curated
and populated and staffed in
such a way that it wouldn't.
I mean, heaven forbid if it
burnt down the Capitol building.
You know the worst thing that
happened is a couple broken
windows.
And a couple shit smeared walls.
I mean, honestly, if it were
real manifestation, it would be
the capitol building would be
perfectly burnt down and the
office buildings would be burnt
down and the entire Capitol Hill
area would be looted and
something would have actually
happened as opposed to basically
violent tourism.
So because it was violent
tourism and meant that the
people involved had a modicum of
respect and they weren't just
going there with with guns a
blazing, There were no Molotov
cocktails.
There were just theoretical pipe
bombs and theoretical bombs that
never went off.
I I always believed that if
something didn't happen, then it
was a Fed narrative or a Edelman
narrative.
I believe that you can say stuff
happened.
You can say that a OC was
killed.
You can say that nobody was
killed, nobody was tortured,
nobody even got a bloody nose or
a broken nail.
Nothing happened.
And yet 1000 people were charged
and went to jail.
And you know, it'll result in
the first US president passed to
go probably to jail, at least to
federal court.
Etcetera, etcetera, etcetera.
So it was 911 but for not for
the Patriot Act, which you know
gives unfettered access to the
privacy of people around the
world and pretty much access to
break all international laws
with regards to.
To agreements that we've made
with regards to what is and
isn't torture, What is and isn't
crimes against humanity.
What is and isn't surveillance.
What does and doesn't break the
Constitution, What does and
doesn't break the trust of the
public?
If you can convince the public
that their safety, their
freedom, their democracy, and so
forth demands the willful and
violent suppression of fascism,
Nazism, cristo, fascism and
tyranny, then you're a freaking
maestro man.
If you can fight fascism with
fascism, if you can wait, if you
can fight despot it despotism
with despotism.
If you can fight
authoritarianism with
authoritarianism, and if you can
put into official channels
oligarchy in order to fight
oligarchy, then bravo.
The future of our world is
definitely going to be safe.
But the future of our world is
going to be at the at the price
of liberty.
And on that note.
Have a great weekend and I love
you and I'll talk to you soon.
Mahalo.
Bye, bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.
Please please.